con e addio muori muori infilato
nell'ano ecco non potete capire
l'epicità di questa roba non potete vi
lascio al video da tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vj vedo oggi siamo su the knight the
pips
ecco mi usciva spontaneo fatto in
quattro giorni ispira e me che non avevo
dubbi perché vista la grafica è molto
fatto bene in quattro giorni presto z to
start va bene lo schiacciante oddio che
addio
ma cos'è ma x quale motivo
dai che cazzo è stara a voi ragazzi vi
spiego la situazione allora è un gioco
oro per quanto questa roba possa essere
horror però è un gioco horror a pixel 9
per scacciare i nemici devi fare questo
è vero non farò non posso andare a
guardare nessuno giu posso solo fare il
dito medio alle cose io vorrei leggere
che cosa c'è scritto però il gioco è
stato fatto in quattro giorni quindi non
c'è in serie già in caso però c'è
l'ombra della mano sei un gioco fatto da
schifo si è fatto da dio non può essere
una via di mezzo [ __ ] lanterna di
merda
[Musica]
ma andate a cagare le cose inanimate
vediamo di proseguire l'onda di qua
queste sono tombe sei morto amati
pisciano addosso deficiente permesso
fatemi entrare in questo altro hai
provato a spaventarmi che morisse il
cugino devo seguire la luce cos'è una
scala bello bello che non vedo niente
ragazzi
sì però state calmi ragazzi che ciò il
dito medio facile allora fatemi capire
cosa deve averne mai esistere un cazzo
di gioco dove per scacciare i nemici
devi fare così
she wolf perfect in every day she was
intelligence chiude fornendo bayern
quindi il mio senso di mandare a fare in
culo e sono stato anche buono quindi da
sito quando la situazione si mette male
io devo fare il dito medio è la gente si
allontanano a vero zio c'è un romani
sottofondo bruttissimo a [ __ ] pecchia
che spaventa la serio questo ma allora
non è un gioco di merda cioè era affatto
bene cazzo non me lo aspettavo sarei
morto se non avessi fatto il dito medio
credo è cioè io vado avanti e ragazzi
non lo so dove sto andando non ne ho
neanche idea però ma devo fare qualcosa
di tirare solo il dito ma c'è un'altra
strada di qua permesso c'è un cadavere
mi piacerebbe sapere se quello è uno
scheletro ma non posso abbassare lo
sguardo quindi va bene non posso
guardare in basso ciò al torcicollo
purtroppo rega sono cose che capitano
quando sta a fare il dito medio a
qualsiasi cosa posso stare perché c'è
una mano sul tavolo rega lei sapeva che
c'era una via d'uscita
lei ha in parte
[Musica]
ragazzi [ __ ] chikos cosa sei
però devi stare calmo è che c'è di
peggio potrei prendermi a schiaffi game
over presto z tu continua perché l'ho
mandato a [ __ ] ma era una tipa non ho
capito cosa fosse però non ha funzionato
rea ma non importa ragazzi perché noi
ciao ti vedo un po pallido deficiente
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] è andata via e andata via
ha funzionato ma un cristiano non si può
manco soffia il naso fattacci tua amata
quindi ha funzionato la funzione al dito
medio e perché prima non lo fa perché
prima ci sono andato io addosso sono un
genio lega va bene e allora andiamo di
qua dove c'era il cadavere perfetto
vabbè l'importante sopravvivere c'è una
porta caduta permesso c'è una è una
sedia non ho ben capito che di che si
tratta prova ancora ma io devo uscito
trovare un'uscita non ho capito che
stavo fare sto gioco devo trovare
un'uscita o ciano porta serve la chiave
all'af ancora cos'è dov'è questo è
successo non ho capito non ho capito che
era successo qualcosa ma non ho capito
cosa va bene basta che palle ma quanti
nemici ci sto non ci sono quello c'è
qualcun altro perché mi sa che c'è anche
qualcun altro lega c'è tipo qualcosa mi
è saltato addosso adesso ma non ho
capito cosa
cos'è sta roba permesso ecco è tornato
qualcosa lega porca [ __ ]
cos'è cos'era
oddio muori muori infilata o nell'anno
ecco c'era qualcos'altro ragazzi ho
schiacciato qualcos'altro tra lui non ho
capito chi o cosa
lei non può trovarla così sta roba è
bruttissimo si avvicina senza che ti
accorgi non ragazzi ma forse si è salute
per l'amor di dio ma cos'è su rumore
batum che brutta cosa ho visto non so
come ho fatto a sopravvivere vai vai
veloce veloce veloce launcher sono
entrato qui dentro un tema bene
interrompiamo programma per presentarvi
il leone cane fifone su un televisore
smic iata
ma cos'è sta roba che mi si para davanti
di tre secondi bruttissimo la [ __ ] che
caga non mi farei mica ripartire
dall'inizio ma dai che palle a malapena
mi oriento normalmente ma come faccio ma
spiegami
[Musica]
all
eva i computer possono gare su facebook
z to pick up
lei è morta ma lei ancora non lo sa ma
dacci sua e se non lo sai sulllo zia
qualcuno che ruota c'è il tipo che ruta
madonna che brutta cosa quando rotta sto
tizio ok in mezzo alle lanterne c'era
qualcosa in quale lanterna preso non è
preso kek ulissi mo in mezzo alle due
lanterne quali lanterne ma manco trovo
le regole non ci credo
c'era una stanza segreta regala sono
entrato bene che brutta cosa
io sono vivo servivo sono rimasto vivo
bene era in mezzo alle lanterne
fantastico trovato la chiave non ci
posso mai credere fatemi uscire sono
incastrato
ma dai ma non è vero ho capito che hai
fatto sto gioco in un giorno ma poteva
ragazzi di scala per uscire se uno cade
qua sotto saltami addosso un'altra volta
per l'amor di dio
ecco perfetto questo lo sapevo ho
trovato la chiave e gentilissimi a gia
vero dietro alla poeta chi la trova più
la porta minchia già un miracoloso
trovato la chiave
ma io posso uscire di qua 600 euro robe
bruttissime [ __ ] ok bene perfetto
lei non lo sapeva che poteva entrare nel
muro io sì è ragazzi devo trovare
l'altra porta non mi ricordo dove
assolutamente non mi ricordo dove la
porta dopo ci metterò due vite e mezzo
per trovarla questo potrebbe essere un
problema
mai nella vita la troverò st porta ma
vasta ruggisce di meno un piccone
[Musica]
ecco l'ho trovata sono forte giorno
che cosa hai sentito le storie ma non te
ne fregate un cazzo vivrai per sempre
benvenuto nell'oscurità sa bene sempre
comunque un finale migliore this land
ermeti end presso inscape to tweet che
bello la mia vita adesso può definirsi
completa d'accordo ragazzi è stato bello
ve lo giuro cazzo come son contento
andata con affanno la serie mettere che
hanno capitolo nel senso di sta roba
nella vita però va beh certo che fare un
gioco dove per vincere devi mandare
affanculo dei mostri e geniale questo
non posso non ammettere che i ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto un bel mi
piace per il video è piaciuto cosa che
mi è piaciuta sotto come tu mi piace a
capaci anni felici per come tratta le
descrizioni sentiti si è felici mi diano
seguito ai ragazzi